well so what happens with with Abraham
well he's at home and these angels show
up no we don't know whether they're
angels or men precisely because well as
this part of the story reads as the Lord
appeared to him in the plains of Mamre
and he sat in the tent door in the heat
of the day so he's not a visionary state
by the by all appearances and he lifted
up his eyes and looked and lo three men
stood by him there's real ambivalence in
the story about the men are the three
men are the three angels are there two
angels in God it's all mixed up in the
story so we won't clarify that we'll
leave it ambiguous and I think the
ambiguity is important because you don't
know who the stranger is when you
encounter them and it depends on whether
you're thinking about it in the
normative manner or if you're thinking
about it in the transcendent manner
because with each person that you meet
well they're just a person that's one
way of thinking about it and and then
they're the person that you know or
they're the person as they choose to
reveal themselves to you and people keep
themselves shielded but then they're
also something of great metaphysical
potential right and you might say well
do you believe that and I would say well
yes you believe it because you expect a
lot from people generally speaking and
are not happy if they betray you but
more importantly our entire culture is
predicated on the idea that each person
has an indefinite intrinsic worth and
I'm not talking about self-esteem I'm
talking about something like the what
what would you say it the implicit
presupposition in our legal structure
that no matter who you are even if
you're a murderer even if you're a
condemned murderer that there's
something about you that's of
transcendent value that has to be
respected by the law by the law and by
other people right and so that's that's
a remark
you might say well you know do I believe
that and the answer that is well yeah it
out because you follow the law and it's
not an easy thing to pull out of the law
it's kind of the idea that you have
intrinsic natural rights and you don't
pull that out of our law man without
having the whole thing fall down and I
think the whole idea that you have
intrinsic natural rights is predicated
on something like the biblical
hypothesis that human beings have a low
ghost nature and that we are involved in
the speaking forth of being and as
beings who are involved in this speaking
forth of being there's something about
us that has to be respected by ourselves
in relationship to ourselves by
ourselves in relationship to other
people but even more strangely by
ourselves in relationship to even to
criminals even to vicious criminals you
can't remove that transcendent element
and that's that to me that's also a
mirror a miracle of conceptualization
because who the hell is going to think
that up right even the most vicious of
murderers has a touch of the
transcendent that needs to be respected
of all the ideas that are unlikely
that's gonna top the list and of course
without that you you have a very
barbaric legal system right because no
one is protected as soon as you make a
mistake then you're in the Damned and
you have no rights whatsoever and that
isn't what happens in the West which is
an absolutely amazing thing so anyways
Abraham is a master of the stranger
that's one way of thinking about it he
knows what to do when strangers come
along and he opens his he opens himself
up to them and I would say he does that
we know he's not a naive guy Abraham
right he's no weakling a couple of
stories ago he took a big army and you
know went and harassed a bunch of Kings
and took his nephew back he's he's a
tough guy and so if strangers show up
and he welcomes them it's not because he
couldn't do otherwise he could certainly
do otherwise and it's not because he
isn't aware of what people can be like
he's perfectly aware of what people can
be like but he determines to take a
particular attitude towards them and
that is to welcome them and so and why
would you do that and I think the answer
to that is you hold out your hand
entrust to someone and you evoke the
best from them if that's their to be
given so it's an act of courage it's
like it's it isn't me meeting you
exactly not exactly it's more like the
transcendent part of me
making a gesture that allows the
transcendent part of you to step forward
and that happens all the time it happens
all the time an enormity of discourse
you know this perfectly well because
sometimes you can have a real casual
conversation with someone that just goes
nowhere right it's just shallow as can
be or now and then you can actually make
contact with someone right and you're
both I would say enlightened and ennoble
by the conversation and that's a de we
would call that a deep conversation
first for some reason because we made a
deep connection whatever that means it
means
well it certainly means that it's not
shallow we're not sure about what these
metaphor means but it means that it
reaches deep inside of you it's
something like that you make direct
person-to-person contact and those sorts
of conversations are replenishing that
that's the right way to think about it
they genuinely are and I think that's
because they provide you with that bread
that's not Material bread that's the
information that you need to to thrive
and and to put yourself together and so
it does matter how you meet someone and
it does matter how you treat them when
you first meet them and it's amazing
I've learned to do this at least in part
partly because I'm a clinical
psychologist I've learned how to talk to
people very rapidly and I have the most
amazing adventures with people in cabs
and when I travel because I'll talk to
them directly right away and they'll
tell me the wildest stories and show me
the craziest things because I'm actually
interested in what they have to say and
I'm not afraid well I'm somewhat afraid
but I'm not I'm not sufficiently afraid
to have that stop me and I'm acting on
the presupposition that the person has
something of great interest to reveal
and that that's a very useful thing to
know too because one of the things
that's really cool about people and you
really learn this as a clinical
psychologist is that if you can get
people talking they're so damn
interesting you can hardly stand it you
know because they have these
idiosyncratic experiences that are only
theirs right they're only theirs
personally no one else could tell the
story and that's the kind of stories
that you want to hear and when they tell
you those stories you learn something
you didn't know and so what that means
is that you can treat the landscape of
strangers as an endless vista of places
to learn things you didn't know
and if you know enough so that you're
satisfied with your life and everything
has ceased to be a tragedy around you
well then you can be comfortable in your
circumscribed domain of of totalitarian
knowledge let's say but if you're if
your life is insufficient and you're
suffering more than you want to and
everything isn't what it should be then
you need to look where you haven't
looked for what you don't have and then
you can look outside beyond you and then
you can make friends with what you don't
understand and that's a huge part of
what this story is about because what
happens is that Abraham welcomes the men
God angels and treats them very well and
reaps a tremendous benefit as a
consequence and then well then the story
reverses ISM and we end up in Sodom and
Gomorrah where the same Angels sojourned
and they're treated terribly and all
hell breaks loose and so that's what the
story is about it's not fundamental now
there's a there's a sexual impropriety
thing going on that I'm also going to
delve into but I don't think that's the
critical issue in the story the critical
issue in the story is how do you act in
the face of the stranger you know
there's a statement in the New Testament
Christ says something like when you when
you do something to the least of people
you do it to me him right and that's a
very difficult statement to understand
too but it's something like it's
something reminiscent of the requirement
to keep the idea of the transcendent
reality of the person in mind at the
same time you keep their proximal
reality in mind to have to have your
mind in two places at the same time when
you're talking to people you know I
learned from a friend of mine in
Montreal who is very socially
sophisticated in some ways whenever
whenever he went into us I was like
going shopping with him and whenever he
went into a store and he talked and and
he had an interaction with a clerk the
first thing he would do is have an
interaction with the clerk you know he
wouldn't have an interaction with the
role of the Clare
he'd like look at the person sort of
take stock of the fact that they were
there and then asked them something
genuine about their job or their store
how they were doing like go into a
conversation right away and he didn't
get personal about it cuz that can be
intrusive right you have to be very
sophisticated to do this but he did
indicate to the person that he was there
at least in part for the good that could
be done between them it's something like
that and then the person would be
ridiculously helpful you know and and so
then you know if people mistreat you you
see this with antisocial kids it's a
very tragic thing to see because if
you're an antisocial child by the time
you're about four you're very hostile
and distrustful to people and so you're
like a growling puppy and if you're a
growling puppy you tend not to get
petted you're more likely to get kicked
and if you're a growling puppy and you
get kicked then you have even more
reason to growl and that's sort of the
story of antisocial kids if they're not
well socialized by the time they're four
and they're more on the aggressive side
then they alienate themselves from the
community and all they get is rejection
well and then they look at the rejection
and they think well to hell with
humanity you know and no wonder they
think that but but the part of the
catastrophe is is that they get what
they evoke and I'm not saying it's their
fault precisely but it doesn't matter
that's still what happens and so you
might ask yourself if you're not getting
from people what you need there is some
possibility that you're not approaching
especially if this happens to you
repeatedly across people and this is a
virtual certainty if it happens to you
repeatedly across people especially if
you have the same bad experience with
people it's not them it's you I would
say three is the limit if something
happens to you once you write it off if
it happens to you twice it's like you
open your eyes but you write it off but
if it happens to you three times it's
probably you or it's the rest of the
world better it's you because you're not
going to change the rest of the world